erwin du théâtre de marioupol sont
encore fumantes le monument est éventrée
vingt-quatre heures après l'attaqué
difficile de savoir ce que sont devenus
les centaines de personnes qui avaient
trouvé refuge cette femme a pu sortir du
bâtiment
séparé environ 800 repas une centaine de
personnes ont fuit en courant tous les
autres sont sous les décombres oui
probablement il y avait une cavité sous
la scène beaucoup de monde était là bas
l'explosion était sur la scène selon les
autorités ukrainiennes l'abri situé sous
le théâtre aurait résisté mais sous les
bombardements les opérations de
sauvetage sont difficiles comme en
témoignent deux rescapés mieux gêner
avec ma mère mes deux enfants et mon
mari y rester sous les décombres le
plafond s'est effondré je suis blessé à
la tête mais je suis vivante sous nos
yeux
j'ai cherché mon mari par tous mais les
gravats sont énormes on ne peut rien
faire à mains nues comme à l'endroit où
il était comme tout est détruit
ces images tournées il ya une semaine
montre le théâtre transformé en refuge
des centaines de femmes et d'enfants se
protéger des bombardements quotidiens
selon ces images satellites les civils
avait pourtant prévenu en écrivant russe
de part et d'autre du bâtiment le mot
enfant moscou dément être à l'origine de
la frappe
sur le dos de l'armée russe c'est bien
sûr un mensonge assiégée depuis deux
semaines marioupol et dévasté plus de
2000 morts 80% de la ville est détruite
selon la mairie les habitants manquent
de tout
tu voyais nous n'avons rien à manger
c'est horrible nous n'avons pas
d'électricité pas de chauffage
rien trente mille habitants fuient
marioupol par les couloirs humanitaires
mais 350000 n'ont toujours pas réussi à
quitter la ville